hey guys welcome back welcome back to
the Samsung stage we're live on GameSpot
its e3 its day two and I'm joined I'm
joined by Dave yeah they from Crytek
Dave what are you gonna show off and
they were showing hunt horrors of the
Gilded Age hunter horizonte so this was
just announced quite recently right when
did you first start talking i think a
week ago we go wow brand-new yeah so in
case people watching haven't heard of it
give us a load I'm like what is hunt
[ __ ] guild big tours of the guilty day
or the Gilded Age yeah I just call the
hunt let's go hutch okay tell you what
yeah hunts a co-op action RPG where you
play a monster hunter in the late
18-hundreds
all right it's all about teaming up with
friends and going out to take down big
ass bosses really I feel like this game
almost like epitomizes all the things
that are popular III this year you've
got co-op which is like everywhere
you've got big monsters which is also
you know you can evolve and various of
the games that's a kind of a big thing
this year and you've also got the kind
of the 1800 setting which we have the
order as well so you guys have seen n to
the future of all the things a 3 is
about and throwing them together in your
game I think we've got some gameplay to
check it as well so we'll throw that up
on the screen and maybe we can talk me
through what's going on sure thing but
em so what's the Kenny ethos behind this
game is it like it's just about having
fun hunting them monsters of your
friends or what's the kind of vibe you
go for it so basically we wanted to make
a game that was all about killing bosses
and you know we loved the setting
because it allowed us to have a world
where there's electricity and guns and
railroads but at the same time there's
also these sort of dark parts the earth
like what you're seeing here which is
the Louisiana bio where you could
imagine these crazy creatures still
exist and a big aspect of the game is
you're hunting down actual myths and
folklore of the time period so this
mission here is about killing something
called the nightmare which which is
actually folklore about a witch that
comes to you when you're sleeping and
like sits on your chest or something oh
yeah yeah it's about sleep paralysis
yeah yeah yeah yeah but we uh we
basically took that idea and turned it
into a boss coup and so we wanted to
have all these cool touch points so if
you're like you see something the game
you could go on Wikipedia and go hey
that was actually a real thing that's
pretty cool so what's going on you see
you're starting off everyone's being
very sneaky
sure so you just shown a track her down
yeah
the game's an RPG so there's a lot of
buildup and player progression and
development leading up to this point but
I think at this point the players are
sort of tracked down the boss and now
they're going to killer so who are these
other enemies then later the reason we
call them the broken but they're
basically Hillbillies it was swamp and
the one thing we definitely want to do
is have a huge variety of different
enemies so we got these guys we got like
voodoo koltes we got on dead and that's
just in this area of the game that it is
actually International mots funny
monster hunting enterprise so one way to
jump through a window though pretty
pretty gen we put that in the game
everybody stop using doors it was like
two inches from the door they jump the
window but anyway won't have a lot of
different creature partying you know
this is one example of some of the
creatures of the game but everywhere you
go in the game every different areas
gonna have a different set of enemies to
fight this is very everybody very much
The Hills Have Eyes yeah these guys are
very Hill to Isis yes they're kind of
like the the twisted black magic
cultists that hide out in the middle of
swamps that you don't know yeah the
other cool thing about the game is we
wanted to get very authentic with the
weaponry yeah and so a lot of the
weapons are very period base you know
you got single action pistols double
action pistols lever-action rifles you
know it's not like a modern gun where
you can just clip reload and shoot
really fast you actually have to reload
each bullet one at a time and so it adds
a cool unique pacing to the game you
don't see in a lot of other games well I
didn't say but he's nice it's actually
pretty deadly and that's you know that
was a big part of the game we didn't
want it to be easy we wanted the women
to be a challenge you are fighting
pretty crazy stuff but we also wanted to
work the aspect of death into the game
and you'll see coming up we have a
pretty unique response SP and that kind
of ties in to that fact that you are
going to die alive but it's okay because
there's a cool aspect to it that plays
out from that so how does each kind of
each encounter each mission condition
it's going to shape up you have to track
then the monster first the boss first or
yeah so there's actually a ton of
mission types that exist outside the
boss fight I can play through and during
the course of that you're kind of
gathering information collecting cues
clues to find out where the bosses are
so you can go hunt down
and the cool part about that is all
those missions are randomly generated so
the two random layout the enemies are
randomized the events within the
missions are randomized so every time
you go and you don't really know what's
going to go on other than hey we're
going to the swamp to kill stuff you
might stumble across some weird ritual
or you might find some dark altar or you
might find some people that have been
kidnapped and you need to be rescued and
so it's kind of cool we you know our
goal and beginning was like hey we'll
make this infinite adventure system
where people can just play over and over
again and just cool [ __ ] happens
and it's unpredictable so it's a it's
looking really cute as well it's just in
CryEngine right yeah this is all in
CryEngine um we built our own you know
gameplay code to do all the random
generation everything but the graphics
and everything it's pretty nice cuz it's
nice to have an engine with all the
bells and whistles that cry of Jabez
house ax a combat work panic into melee
combat there's an intercom it's kind of
like a conserve ammo mechanism you know
resources are limiting this game you
don't have infinite ammo so it's really
big deal to find ammo to find oil for
your Lantern and so the may lead
something you use when you're kind of
low on ammo or you want to conserve ammo
but it's actually pretty deadly d it's
deadly against the enemies but it's also
dangerous for you because you have to
close up get close and as I said earlier
it the enemies are pretty tough on this
example the respawn system so when you
die you actually appear somewhere on the
map randomly you might be in a coffin or
hanging from a rope this guy appeared in
a coffin so he's actually looking out
through the cross on the door it's like
a Mia yeah basically and so you gotta
wait for one of your friends to come up
to rescue which is pretty cool so what
well the best way is to work together
then what's your best tactics in this
game when you're you get is depend on
things I hosted the enemies are really
tops you got to stick together you get
wounded and yeah this guy's actually
wounded he's gonna die but you go into a
wounded state and you're a lot slower
and more vulnerable but players can come
over and assist you and help you out of
that state but a big part of the tactics
is how you build your character and one
thing we want to do is we have well it's
like a flexible loadout system you can
build your own archetype there's no
defined classes and so you can pick your
weapons the way your guy looks and it's
really and your abilities and so how you
clip the abilities with the other group
some players in the group it dictates
the tactics so you might bring medical
bag so you can help Hill people I might
bring dynamite so I can blow up phrases
and you know we have more supernatural
stuff that's in the game to that you get
from meeting the bosses so it's really
about that team loadout and how you go
in and
tackle to fight that a lot of the coop
elements of the game come to play
reloading so we what what's your was
your cadet inspirations for this because
I mean one of the games back into the
game spot UK office where I'm based in
London again we play more than anything
else so I together is left 4 dead 2
right just great fun for dropping in
playing if you ranch then going home I
mean you go for a similar type of vibe
with this game is yeah I think that you
know we love co-op you know even a lot
of us came from Darksiders a vigil and
we always wanted to make that game four
player co-op you know we love Diablo
left for dead you know mmo's any game
it's just fun to get there with a group
of guys and I think one of the things we
definitely took from left4dead is that
like session-based
like you go in it's a 10 20 minute
mission and then you're done and you can
do the next one we wanted to build a
game that was you know much more diverse
you got tons of different enemies you
got a whole RPG progression system you
have tons of cool boss fights and so
yeah definitely doing all that together
in these quick little cool burst
sessions is just a lot of fun so you get
flamethrowers you get man you get a
whole bunch of different weaponry yeah
the flamethrower school because um one
cool thing to play with is the idea of
future tech in the 1880s yeah ed
flamethrowers on World War one right and
they had ematic weapons in World War one
so we kind of imagined that hey yeah you
got these period 1880 weapons but at
some point as you get better you start
to play with the future technology which
at the time is stuff that was in like
the 1890s or 1910 and so it allows us
introduced some interesting weapons yeah
this guy was depp died he's now hanging
upside down it's kind of cool ISA sees
the whole fight from his vantage point
yeah pretty vulnerable yeah so if you
don't save him I could enemies come and
kill him again yeah you can die and it's
actually the game's friendly fire you
can actually kill them on the rope but
the game's definitely balanced to the
where you need the other players to
survive so I mean if you really want to
sure you could leave them hanging but so
you could roast him right there yeah no
[ __ ]
I think he's gonna save them they're
exactly in your best interest to help
save guys so that you have a full team
of four players
so I remind me what what systems is a
hunt coming on so it's gonna be on pc
and next-gen consoles you see in next
year right ok listen to a good example
um there's a bunch items in the game
that aren't guns anywhere from like
dynamite or a medical bag to a little
more occult or fantastical things that
you kind of build based on the enemies
you defeat that's just a simple one that
kind of shows you where to go oh that
was just that was just here pastor yeah
that's something someone with them
wouldn't have chosen to bring in the
fight it's not automatic but there's
tons of different items like that we're
not talking about them now because
honestly we haven't finalized them all
yet well yeah you're in but that's also
a big part of the game and that loadout
aspect of preparing for the battle with
your friends so this is the this is
actually the boss the nightmare which is
her uh boss arena so would you will of
course you meet her in a graveyard horse
one thing we want to do too is a lot in
the boss fights we want to encourage
cooperative mechanics and you'll see a
pretty cool one coming up where the
nightmare which actually pulls one of
the players into our Nightmare Realm and
when that happens they're the only
player that can see the witch and no one
else can the face shoot the witch then
basically everybody else can see her for
a second she kind of flashes so that guy
kinda has to shoot the witch to keep her
mark so every else can attack and we
want to try to build those type of
cooperative mechanics in the boss fights
so they're not just straightforward boss
fights for guys with guns so DG um for
inspiration for your boss see did you
feel like full floor and everything yeah
here it is I'm it definitely starts as
folklore and then it's you know a bunch
of imagination on top of that you know
cuz the full floors are pretty basic
it's like haters in which it comes me
when you're sleeping and sleeps on your
blades on your chest like okay how do we
turn that into a boss fight and so you
know there's a lot of creativity that
goes on top of that but this what you
see her reappearing there because this
guy's yeah this guy in the which mode
right now
he's shooting her and then when it
switches to the other guy's view you'll
see her like popping every once a while
when he hits her and then they can
that's where they know where they are
where she is at they can hit
back back so there's something taking
place and they kind of mentioned the
kind of hillbilly small flags apartment
like what other type of places will when
you get to go and so we'll be talking
about that coming up but I mean it's
definitely you know there's a lot of
cool opportunity in the time beard
because you could be anywhere from New
York or London that's pretty advanced
for the time period to like you know
Romania or South America that's really
backwater so there's a lot of diversity
and locales and I think you know the key
here you know one thing that's cool here
is it's like these are ordinary guys
fighting these extraordinary bosses and
not superheroes or not you know secret
agents they're just like dudes that
picked up a shotgun and said hey we need
to kill that witch pissing us off let's
go take her out here you can see she
actually pulls another one of the
players in the Nightmare Realm that's
not good that's right yeah Hunt's
horrors of the Gilded Age brilliant yeah
well um if you're watching at home and
you have any questions because it might
be the first time you ever seen hunt so
the best thing to do would be to tweet
directly at me at cam Franz Rob and I'm
up throws questions straight today right
here I saw I still got a couple more
things I wanted to ask you just
basically about like about the before
player co-op and like sure if I can you
can you play with just two people just
with three people with yeah you can play
with any combination a wonderful player
okay right I mean there are some like
really tough bosses in the game that
you're definitely gonna want to team up
with some other players in a scale so if
you have four people on the bosses home
yeah well the game the most of the game
scales but like I said there will be
like epic encounters where you need a
full contingent of four guys or you need
to be really really good to take it down
by yourself but so I mean we mentioned
left4dead see but one of the games if
you get a look at or other kind of media
that you look at for inspiration for man
I mean tons of game leopard at resident
evils another great inspiration just the
types of enemies and the pacing and that
sort of thing
you know last of us I don't I mean it's
one of the things when you make games
you just look at everything that's like
everything is built on the mountain
jeggings you picked the your favorite
bits from the other family but really
the one of the game we thought was cool
was this hey here's a club game that's
focused on killing bosses and that's not
really a lot of games like that you know
so and that was really what it was out
let's make this cool sessoms based boss
hunting game and that's what we made why
did you choose the kind of 18-hundreds
kind of time period like I think again
it was just the diversity and the
environments and the setting of the
technology it's actually a really
interesting time period you know all
kinds of crazy stuff was invented - like
transistors and electricity and crazy
stuff you wouldn't even imagine there
was a minute that time period was so
it's just it was a great and at the same
time there's still crazy places like the
swamp or a nightmare which is my - hung
out people didn't know because they
didn't have cameras or phones or
anything like that we go which she's
waiting well there any other type of
losses you can kind of tease well the
type of beeping your creatures well
might we be coming up again um you know
I don't know I would say you can look if
you wanted to start you can look from
Louisiana and look up folklore and I
think we've nailed pretty much all the
major ones in that area but yeah I mean
it's that's the thing is with because
it's based on myths and folklore it's
they're pretty diverse like this case
it's a which some other case it's this
weird Gator creature that was mixed with
a baboon you know we take these basic
nuggets and we turn them into cool boss
fights and that's kind of the idea
behind the game so but the cool thing is
there's a ton of variety and what's
already out there even within the
existing folklore if I should got a few
questions come over over Twitter do I
know five throw the nine yes so we have
is um
Stewart Hawkins wonders can I have three
AI buddies to play with me uh right now
we don't have any plans for doing AI
okay got it but you can play by yourself
or you can play with two players or
three players so how about the game
world how open are these areas that's
what as come so that way that depends on
the mission some of the missions like
this ones are a little more linear where
it's more directed some of the missions
do open up a little more and again that
gets back to the random nature you don't
know it might come in it might be hey
gotta get escaped out of the swamp or
you might come in and say hey here's a
little open area with farmhouses and you
need to rescue a bunch of people that
are hidden and it's a little more
open-ended so it really varies we wanted
to create as much diversity in the
experience as possible who um other
questions as well from a from plant
brandon lizard and he asks what are some
of the direct inspiration we can add
this yeah the demo had a lot when you
see thinks the demo had a large
Lovecraft theme I'm not sure I know what
Lovecraft is yeah Lovecraft's like call
kethu that sort of thing
yeah I mean yeah that's definitely
that's a huge inspiration I will say
that we will definitely have some
Cthulhu inspired creatures in the game
fantastic Thank You Lee
well David it's been a pleasure having
you on stage man it's been great to chat
yeah thank you it's great to see the
game in action for 50 for the first time
I think for a lot of our audience - so
best of luck with that hopefully we'll
see it maybe at Gamescom maybe it's
coming up with definitely games going oh
definitely against oh really okay
and if people are a three they can go to
your booth then they can they can check
out that demo yeah they can say the cool
high-res version of that video with the
great sound and everything antastic
okay well I thanks very much again man
and guys we are gonna throw over now - I
saw I think a different demo from
somewhere else on the show floor
somewhere we will be back in this stage
as always in about two to three minutes
so don't go anywhere and I'll see that